todos los elementos de una sucesión
cumplen una regla
veamos la siguiente sucesión de figuras
cómo va cambiando la figura uno tiene
tres cuadrados la siguiente tiene cinco
la tercera siete y por último la figura
cuatro tiene nueve cuadrados con esto
podemos decir que el patrón de las
sucesiones dos porque tres más dos es 55
más 12 7 y 7 + 2 es 9 supongamos que
quisiéramos saber cuántos cuadrados
tendrá la figura 20 cuántos las 50 o
cuántos la 80 te imaginas lo cansado que
sería dibujar 20 50 u 80 figuras y
después contar el número de cuadritos
para saber cuántos tiene además de
cansado sería tardar y ximo por eso
necesitamos una fórmula que nos ayuda a
calcular el total de cuadrados de
cualquier figura sin necesidad de seguir
toda la sucesión
entonces si queremos saber el número de
cuadrados que habrá en la figura 80 como
lo hacemos con mucha atención
necesitamos relacionar el número de la
figura es decir la posición con el
número de cuadrados que tiene osea con
el término para determinar el número de
cuadrados en la figura 1 podemos hacerlo
sumando uno más dos porque es uno más
dos es igual a tres pero si lo
intentamos con la figura 2 ya no
funciona porque dos más dos son cuatro y
lo que queremos obtener el 5 y creo que
aunque lo intentemos con todas las otras
figuras esta regla no nos sirve probemos
con otra
pensemos en multiplicaciones 1 por 3 es
igual a 3 pero funciona con el segundo
término 2 por 3 es igual a 6 nos basamos
porque nuestro segundo término 5
probemos con el tercero 3 por 3 es 9 y
no tenemos 7 en el término y con el
cuarto 4 por 3 nos va a voces así que
tampoco porque nuestro término
9 entonces seamos creativos recordemos
que la sucesión va de dos en dos que tal
esta operación si multiplicamos el uno
por dos nos da dos y si sumamos uno
obtenemos tres veamos qué pasa con el
segundo término 2 por 2 es igual a 4 más
15 bien creo que este sí está
funcionando con el tercer término 3 por
2 igual a 6 + 1 obtenemos 7 perfecto si
funciona con la figura 4 habremos
encontrado la regla general 4 por 2 es
igual a 8 más 19 excelente quiere decir
que nuestra regla es multiplicar el
número de la posición por 2 y sumarle 1
si queremos saber cuántos cuadrados
tendrá en total la figura 80 lo que
debemos hacer es multiplicar 80 por 2 y
obtenemos 160 más 1 161
nuestra figura 80 tendrá 161 cuadrados
80 de un lado 80 del otro más 1 que
siempre está en medio viste qué fácil
fue te voy a dar un consejo es muy
importante que para resolver este tipo
de operaciones no te confundas con la
posición y con el término
muy bien lo que hicimos fue formular la
regla general de una sucesión
determinada ahora
ayúdame a hacerlo al revés qué quiere
decir esto que a partir de la regla
general vamos a construir la sucesión
tenemos la siguiente regla el número de
posición x 4 - 2 sabes cómo lo haremos
analicemos nuestra regla
dice que el número de posición lo
multiplicamos por cuatro y le restemos
dos para encontrar el primer término de
la sucesión entonces tomamos la posición
1 ese uno lo multiplicamos por 4 1 por 4
4 y por último como dice la regla le
restamos dos entonces cuatro menos dos
es igual a dos listo encontramos el
primer término de la sucesión
para continuar tomamos la segunda
posición o sea el 2 y lo multiplicamos
por 4 2 por 4 82 obtenemos 6 vamos por
la tercera posición de la sucesión 3 por
4 es igual a 12 menos 2 tenemos 10 creo
que ya te diste cuenta de cómo estamos
construyendo nuestra sucesión para que
queda aún más claro
sigamos 4 x 4 igual a 16 menos 2 14 5
por 4 es igual a 20 menos 218 muy bien
entonces tenemos 2
10 14 18 y el patrón de cambio en
nuestra sucesión es 4 sin embargo
recuerda que para encontrar términos
futuros no podemos decir que el patrón
de cambios 4 o que va cambiando de
cuatro en cuatro porque esa solo sería
la regularidad la regla general sería el
número de posición por cuatro menos dos
perfecto así que no dejes de encontrar
reglas que te ayuden a crear más
términos en las sucesiones